جميع الصم في الوطن العربي نقدم لكم احداث
غزه بلغه الاشاره
[موسيقى]
نبدا من تحت دمار غزه العظيم ينجو الطفل
الرضيع الا قليلا لان يدا ما الهيه اسعفت
فتعالى ضحكته وتجل جل بقدر ما تستطيع
الحنجره الغضه في عمر لا يتعدى بضعه شهور
او بقدر ما يتسع الفضاء المتخم بعويل
الامهات الكاله وهدير الطائرات الحربيه
ودوي الصواريخ الفتاكه فوق قطعه ارض شديده
الضيق اسمها قطاع غزه وطالما استخدمت سجنا
كبيرا لما يزيد عن مليوني انسان قبل ان
تتحول اخيرا الى ما يشبه منطقه زلزال لم
يبقي ولم يذر الاولاد وين ح يي بكفي يا
عالم بكفي بكفي احنا ناس غلابه اقسم
والولاد ماتوا بدون ما ياكلوا كانوا مل
القلب والعين ثم في لحظه غادره تفتت او
تشظت اجسادهم ودفنوا بين ركام بيتهم
المدمر يكتشف اب مكلوم ايضا ويهذي بصوت
مسموع حين يعرف ان فلذات كبده التي كانت
بالامس تمشي على الارض او تجري الى حضنه
وتتسلق كتفيه قد صارت تحت التراب ولم يت
بقى له من كل تلك الحياه غير ظلال الوان
تحز الروح حز السكاكين الله يسهل عليكم يا
اولادي ودي وزوجتي وام وابويا واخويا
واولاده 17
نفر كلهم صغار لا يوجد الا شاب واحد لا
تخل صور الموت في غزه بالطابع من اطفال
اخرين اخطائهم القصف الجهنمي او لعله
اجلهم الى زمن قادم ليذيقهم مراره اليتم
بقتل ابائهم وامهاتهم او ليعرفوا قبلا وجع
الفقد بخساره اشقائهم ورفاق صباهم قب القر
عاو بعدين اخويا زعق علي يا جمال
يامال والله الفاعل هنا ليس مجهولا انه
اسرائيل الدوله التي شردت اباء هؤلاء
واجدادهم منذ 75 سنه عن ديارهم وظلت
تلاحقهم ون لهم في مخيمات اللجوء بالقصف
العنيف والقتل العشوائي والمذابح المتكرره
وصولا الى ما يصفها كثيرون منهم الان
بانها حرب
اباد لكن العالم ولا سما الجزء الذي يسمي
نفسه بالحر مازال يتصرف ازاء قتل مئات
الاطفال كما لو انه لا يرى نزيف دمهم ولا
يسمع عويل ذويهم او كما لو انه مقتنع بوصف
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي لهؤلاء بانهم
حيوانات على هيئه بشر وليس متوقعا منهم
والحال هذه ضحكا او بكاء يثير شجن الامهات
ويستدعي تعاطف الاباء في اوساط
الغرب سيتذكر الفلسطينيون هنا ان الغرب
الذي يتجاهل موتهم الجماعي المتلفز هو
ذاته الذي يحرص على التعبير دوما عما
يسميها حضارته بتجنيد امكاناته لانقاذ
مجموعه حيتان تائها في القطب الشمالي
وتتابع من صيد الفيله في اسيا ويخصص
ملايين الدولارات لانقاذ زواحف نادره من
الانقراض حسنا اذا ثمه في غزه قطط وكلاب
تقتلها صواريخ الطائرات الاسرائيليه ايضا
ايها الساده قد يقول فلسطينيون ما بينما
يقدم اخر امام الكاميرات دليلا حاسما على
وجود يستحق مصارعه الغرب لاثبات
تحضره واخيرا السلام
عليكم